how to make money
so i got a question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
card games tv one wrote in what item is
cheap to buy
but you can sell for more on ebay this
question frustrates me
i get that you're trying to make money
okay we all want to make money
maybe maybe you're in a lot of debt
maybe you
you made a gamble didn't pay off maybe
you're trying to escape your life that
you're at now you're trying to build a
better life for yourself and
you know go to better circumstances and
money helps you get there i get it you
want money that's great
but the way to do it the way to make
money
isn't to try to find something cheap and
sell it for more
that's not how you make a lot of money
you make a lot of money by following
your passion
and doing something that really helps
people
you want to make a lot of money you need
to provide a lot of value
you want to make a lot of money quickly
provide a lot of value quickly
it's not going to come by selling
finding some cheap product
for a dollar and selling it for 10 on
ebay that's not how you're going to make
a lot of money because
you don't love this thing and you're not
adding a lot of value
think about how you can add value it
reminds me of a story of somebody i know
and it's a really sad story this guy bet
big on his dream
okay he bet big on on this business idea
that he had
and it took out a huge loan took out a
huge huge loan
and uh and it didn't work out it didn't
work out mostly because
he didn't have the experience okay he
had a passion but he didn't have the
experience and he ran out of time
and now he is he is suffering with
crippling debt just massive debt that
all
he thinks about is money all he thinks
about is money
if there is a a chance to make an
opportunity to make some money he's
going to jump on it
and he's running five or six businesses
all at the same time
always working weekends always working
this guy is just slammed
constantly working and it's had you know
an impact
on on his personal life as well not just
his
his business and none of his businesses
are taking off
and he's constantly struggling it's
because he hasn't poured himself into
any of them right
he's just trying to look for a way to
get rich quick it doesn't happen that
way
okay he might eke out a living
okay he can earn a little bit of a
living and you can start paying off some
of that debt
but he's not going to be massively
successful you cannot
be massively successful doing things
that you don't love
it's that simple running five businesses
just trying to make a quick buck putting
everybody in your life
you know at risk and and not having
great relationships that's not the path
to success and i get that it all comes
from this desire
it's so hard it can be so hard to see
the path
when you're struggling you have
crippling debt
you have so many people pressuring you
to get money
that that's all you focus on and as
society
we're kind of trained to do that right
we're trained to go
to go make money and to get a bigger
house and to take on debt
where do we learn about following our
passion
and really building great things but
that's the path
that has to be the path and if you're in
that situation where you've got a ton of
debt
you have to find something that is
unique to you
something that you love doing something
that will help other people and start
doing that even if it's on the side part
time
you have to start doing that you have to
find
that unique thing that can really make a
difference in people's lives that can
really really benefit them and something
that you can pour
everything you've got into because it's
not going to come
by finding cheap products and selling
them for a profit on ebay
that's not your path that's not the path
it has to be something that you love
believe for those of you watching like
the video thumbs up below
leave a comment let me know what you
think ask me a question below and click
on my face if you want to see more
videos like this
thank you so much